it's not just biden's policies that are
causing people to second-guess their
allegiance to the democrat party it's
also because of everything the left has
come to embrace now two nights ago we
showed you shocking undercover video
from a teacher in santa barbara
california she bravely brought to light
this vile
racializing of her school curricula and
what the school district district was
trying to hide from the parents by the
way on what was a password protected
portal
i want to show you what's being
concealed from the parents in the santa
barbara unified school district
inclusive
curriculum lessons
there's collections the lgbtq heritage
gender inclusive biology
educate and celebrate there's activism
the youth advocate toolkit preschool
grade school
and secondary resources
well that courageous teacher christy
lozano saw our segment and agreed to
come on tonight
christy thanks for being with us um have
you gotten any blow back
since we helped you expose this
nationwide
not really i've had a lot of positive
feedback uh for the most part um
i'm sure people are thinking things but
i haven't had too much so that's good
well you know california is obviously
extremely liberal
i spend quite a bit of time believe it
or not i'll come visit you in santa
barbara so i know it pretty well but i
think at this point they've gone
they've gone they've gone so far left
they i say this they've left america
that's what it looks like so i want to
play more of your video where you expose
this racialized lesson plan watch
105 things white people can do for
racial justice
white people do something
it's basically defunding the police and
a new smarter approach to public safety
says to donate to blm
make small crimes legal
do not support prisons
and reduce prison sentences
christy who's behind these lesson plans
do the teachers for the most part
endorse this do they resist it and what
about the parents
well
the who's behind the lesson plans um
they've hired somebody to come in and
write these plans i think they just
hired him this year
and
i think they come from other areas where
they have done the same things maybe
even taken over the school district in
other areas like san francisco
salinas
and the teachers
we
a lot of the teachers do endorse it
some go along with it because they think
it's the trend
and um
it and you're made to feel bad if you
don't and if you don't you know
go along be politically correct or
whatever they want to say
and in santa barbara
they've been doing teacher trainings for
us for the last 10 to 15 years where
they've pretty much indoctrinated the
teachers
to then indoctrinate the students and
even during those trainings i knew
something was wrong so i've known that
for a long time i just know what so so
it becomes a self-selecting
group of people who would want to teach
this sorry crap okay yes i mean most
teachers the people who taught me were
just great teachers men women young old
they were amazing public school teachers
i can't imagine
any of them would have ever tolerated
being told you have to teach basically
woke activism it wasn't called woke back
then but basically left-wing activism
they wouldn't have done it
yeah they they make you believe it's
very manipulative you know i call it
psychological warfare
and it's hard to uh understand because
it's manipulation they'll lie to your
face they'll tell you that this is the
right thing to do they'll make you feel
bad if you don't do it
and
so people go along with it for fear of
standing out for fear of being different
but
um
and for fear and it's a real fear
because there's retaliation i've been
retaliated on for speaking up for quite
a while now so
um but i'm not the type that moves away
from danger i move towards it i'm a
veteran of the us air force and that's
what i've been taught so and i protect
kids
kids are why i teach i love kids and i
will protect them and i will go down
fighting if i need to
well christy it's turning child against
child which is just a terrible terrible
thing to do children tend to see the
world as a colorblind place unless you
you know stoke that kind of thinking in
them and it's it's super sad and super
counterproductive thank you for speaking
out christy keep us informed and
encourage more teachers
to do the same and we're going to do our
part nationwide thank you so much hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else